παράδειγμα ότι δεν είναι μόνο πρόβληματα επιτόκια και σου λέω σένα θυσία να σου δώσο
αύριο ένα εκατομύριο ένα εκατομύριο δώρε ν χρήμα χωρίς μεμι δεν επιτόκειο και να μου
το αποπληρώσει ε πέτε χρόνια το παίρνεις ίδεν το παίρνεις το μεγάλο ορώδήμα είναι πως
θα το αξιοποιήσεις το ένα κατομύριο γιατί πάλι νεβάνειο πάλι θα το αποπληρώεις δεν είναι
δώρο αρα πρέπει να υπάρχουν και να υπάρχει μια επιχειρηματική δράσει που να δει διευκαιρίες
και σε νεούς και γενικότερα στον αναπτύξουν είτε τες κανωδόμες ιδές τους που έχουμε κάνει
βήματα προς ταπρος αλλά δεν είμαστε εκεί που πρέπε είμαστε πίσω θεωραρακόμησε δεν είναι μόνο
δεν είναι μόνο εγώσου λέο ότι να ρωτήσεις δεκτο μα στο δρόμο ι εννέα θα
σοπ όχι δεν τα παίρνο γιατί το βάνει είναι δάνειο άρα δεν είναι μόνο πρόβλημα
το εψηλοπιτοκαιο ιείναι και άλλα πράγματα που φοβίζουν τον κόσμο είναι βεβαια ότητα γιατί βλέα
πουμε ότι τα πράγματα αλλάζουν πάρα πολεί ρήγορα και ναι όσον αφορά την επιχρηνηματικότητα έχουμε
δρόμο να διανίσουμε είχαμε χουμε τους παραδιωσιακούς τομίς που πάνε καλά ότουρισμός α οπο διαγοράκινήτο
λά χρειαζόμαστε και πιο καινοτόμες λύσεις και νοτόμες επιχειρήσεις που θαφύγουμε και λίγο από αυτό
το παραδοσι κόμοντέλλο με τον τουρισμό την επιχιρηματικές υπηρεσίες που μας έχουν στηρίξει για πάρα
πολλές δεκαϊτίες και θα συνεχίσουν ν μακα τορίσουμες πάντα ήταν οι ένση τον οτική έναι
συστην ικό νοείναι άνεσο ταδίσουείναι και άμεσως ο αντίκτυπος είναι άμεσως ααντίχτυπος παίνει το χρήμα
άμεσα στην αγορά δε χρειάζεται τόσο πολλά τός ο πολύ μακροπρόθεσμος σκεδιασμός και ευτυχώς και
πέρσει και φέτος προβλέπονται χρονίες δωλικόρ θεωρίσεται ωρές αυτές οι εξαγγελέες από τον πρόεδρο ακόμε
και σήμερα που γάνομε αυτό το γύρις μα έχει εξαγγελία πασυσχαλημέ επίδο μας σε έχα
μηλασυντιάξει γος πρέπει να μας φοβίζει ότι ίσωςζούμε παραδείγματα που είχαμε επαλιά